the first trailer for Black Widow the
solo vehicle for the heroic Avenger is
finally here and it is pretty
spectacular there's plenty to unpack in
the spot but with all of the insane
action there are a few details that you
may have missed fortunately we're pretty
good at spotting those the trailer opens
on a panoramic view of a city one which
might not be immediately familiar to
American eyes that statue in the center
of the shot is pretty distinctive
however and if you already have a gut
feeling as to what this setting might be
let us go ahead and confirm it for you
that installation is called the Liberty
statue and it watches over the great
Hungarian capital of Budapest now a few
of you may be asking so what for the
rest of you we'll give you a second to
pick your jaws up off the floor
you'll recall that during the absolute
mayhem that was the Battle of New York
in 2012's The Avengers
Natasha Romanoff and Clint Barton had a
humorous exchange while they were smack
dab in the middle of shooting and
arrowing the heck out of the invading
Chitauri hordes it seems highly unlikely
that this would be a mere coincidence
it's also worth noting that after this
shot dissolves to a montage of previous
Marvel films where the Romanovs
voiceover wistfully recapping the road
to her family and the Avengers the first
recognizable character we see is Barton
wil Hawkeye join in on the action in
Black Widow we feel pretty safe and
guessing that he will after a very widow
in Marvel Studios card we see Romanoff
arriving at Budapest train station
followed by a shot of what appears to be
a convoy of military vehicles headed to
an unknown location we then briefly see
who is leading that convoy general
Thaddeus Thunderbolt Ross who is not the
biggest fan of the Avengers you'll
recall that during Civil War Romanoff
was on the pro registration team led by
Iron Man however during the enormous
brawl at a German Airport she had a
slight change of heart allowing Captain
America and Bucky Barnes to escape while
the rest of caps anti-registration team
was captured and hauled off to the raft
super prison Romanovs role in helping
them skedaddle would not have been lost
on Ross who almost certainly has designs
on making sure she ends up cooling her
heels on the raft as well
course we know that she eventually joins
rogers on Sam Wilson on the run ending
up in Scotland where we catch up with
the trio during the first act of
Avengers infinity war this likely means
that Ross won't have any luck bringing
the Black Widow in but that doesn't mean
he won't be a major thorn in her side
the spot finally gives us our first look
at an iconic Marvel villain taskmaster
who in the comics is capable of
perfectly replicating the fighting
styles of anyone he might encounter the
baddie super muscle-memory also allows
him to use any weapon after observing
it's use just once and you will notice
that in the Black Widow trailer he's
using a weapon that we've only ever seen
one MCU character employee before a
character who just happens to have very
close ties to Romanoff we suppose this
could be a coincidence or a mere
aesthetic choice but we do find it a bit
odd that taskmaster would be channeling
Barton in his first appearance in the
trailer we'd also like to point out that
we're using the descriptor he because
taskmaster is male in the comics but
it's not at all clear that this is the
case here the actor portraying the
villain hasn't been disclosed and it
stands to reason that this is a detail
that Marvel has been keeping under lock
and key for a reason the taskmaster of
the MCU could very well be female and
could in fact even be one of Romanovs
family as we see in a brief scene around
a dining room table this family includes
Yelina Bulova with whom Romanoff has a
nice friendly fight near the opening of
the spot and with whom at points in the
comics that shares the black widow
moniker Alexi Shostak Oh aka the red
Guardian rushes answer to Captain
America and Melina Vostok off who we
first see briefly wearing a very Widow
II outfit we know that Bulova and bosta
cough are products of the same Red Room
training that molded Romanoff into a
deadly weapon
but in bosta coughs case in particular
we don't necessarily know what her
motives will be in the comics bosta
cough is known as the iron maiden and
she's driven by a deep-seated hatred of
Black Widow whose shadow she has never
been able to escape she's even tried to
assassinate Romanov so if the character
indeed remains an ally throughout this
film it will represent a complete 180
from her comics ink Renee ssin we were
heartened to see that David Harper who
was earned household name status thanks
to his role as chief Jim hopper and
stranger things didn't get crazy jacked
for his role indeed
he's just as doughy yet he still manages
to squeeze into his old suit to join the
ass-kicking party and kick ass he does
in a very brief shot we see him going
toe-to-toe with taskmaster an extremely
dangerous opponent if ever there was one
and holding his own unfortunately we
only see a literal second of the fight
but if we're being honest all we can
hope for is that it isn't the last scene
in which red Guardian appears Harbor is
an extremely endearing actor his few
appearances in this trailer have us
anxious to see more of Costa Cove and
that old costume even looks pretty
badass but it's obvious that the
Guardian hasn't seen action for quite
some time there have to be some high
stakes involved in Black Widow and what
we're saying here is that we really
really hope that the Guardian survives
this fight unlike well
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]